[Music]
hi I'm Toby and welcome to the joy of
mathematics I'm so glad you could join
me today I'm going to run some ideas
across the bottom of the screen and
these are ideas which we will come to
understand today it's another beautiful
day outside today although it is a
little windy I've gone ahead and already
drawn a tree for us but a tree is a
little bit like an iceberg in that what
you can see on the surface is only a
small part of the story what is going to
be really important to us today is what
we can see under ground a tree could not
exist without its roots now last time I
saw you we were talking about logarithms
and how they can be used to rewrite
exponents one particularly popular
exponent is the square a number times
itself we could have 3 times 3 is equal
to 9 4 times 4 which is 16 or even 5
times 5 which is 25 these are all
squares and could be written as 3
squared 4 squared or 5 squared but what
had some leaves carried by the wind with
to come across and land right here and
right here so that all we could see was
the result we knew that something
squared was equal to 16 but we couldn't
quite remember what well what we would
need to do would be to find the square
root of 16 roots are what allow a tree
to grow the better the roots the more
nutrients they can collect and the more
support they can provide just like in
life having support can make it feel
easier to achieve great things
although support can often be hard to
come by or difficult to recognize
just drawing in our roots here
you can see these roots would be very
good at providing some moral and
structural support to the tree we also
forgot to add the Apple to our tree
before so we can go ahead and sneak that
in now now in these square roots
there are 16 units of dead that's the
area of the square an area of a square
is calculated from its base times its
height and since these are the same if
we know the length of just one side we
know the square root we can go ahead and
divide this up into a grid and if the
length of each side was 3 then we would
have 9 units of debt but if instead it
was 5 on each side we would have 25
units of debt but the sweet spot for us
and you're going to see it here is that
if each link of the roots each side of
the square is 4 units long and in total
we will have 16 units of dirt sitting
right here in our roots and that's
exactly what we wanted so we know that
the square root of 16 will be equal to 4
all these numbers that I've mentioned 9
16 25 they're all called perfect squares
because they are the squares of whole
numbers we could look at a non-perfect
square say 20 although all numbers are
perfect in their own way and we could
look well 20 is between 16 and 25 so the
square root of 20 would be somewhere
between 4 and 5 and in fact it is 4
point 4 7 now there's actually another
solution to all of these square roots
and I hate to mention it as an hour
I thought because nobody likes being an
afterthought but we could have also had
for example - four times - for being
equal to 16 because two wrongs make a
right but in our case having a negative
side length wouldn't make a lot of sense
so we were fine
to just take the positive solution there
is actually a symbol that tells us to
look underground and find the square
root of a number and that is this heart
beat kind of symbol here called the
radical because it is pretty radically
cool now I remember when I very first
encountered the symbol on some math
homework at school but I was pretty
confused because I had never seen it
before I didn't know what it was called
and I didn't know how to find out I
wanted to google it but I didn't know
how to describe it in the Google search
do use type in tick like symbol or
heartbeat I kind of liked the name
heartbeat symbol now if you like me you
might be a little bit curious as to the
root of this square root symbol and
there seems to be a little bit of
disagreement about where exactly it
comes from one story that I've heard as
to its origin is that it comes from the
Arabic word for root and it comes from
the first letter of the word which looks
a little bit like this the Latin word
for root is actually radix and it comes
from radix quadratum which actually
means the side of a square some
mathematicians wrote this as capital R X
now that might have made its way to
becoming the modern symbol or it might
have also come from a lowercase R also
for ratings but there's one more
possible origin story and that is that
some mathematicians used to denote a
square root as putting a dot or a few
dots above the numbers that they wanted
to take the square
and it's thought that maybe somewhere
along the way these dots just acquired a
bit of an upstroke and that became our
symbol what we do know is that in 1637
Descartes was the first to use the
square root symbol with this line over
the top that has a name it's called the
van keulen and that includes everybody
in the square root who was supposed to
be there it's like a big group hug the
square root symbol typically means to
just take the principal or the positive
result of the square root so there is
only one leaf that would satisfy the
square root of 16 is equal to leaf only
one solution would satisfy that but
instance did we were to have leaf
squared is equal to 16 there are two
Leafs that would satisfy this and we
would have to write our answer as being
plus or minus 4 the square root can also
just as easily be written as 16 to the
half we can start using fractional
powers and for other roots say the cube
root we will just extend this to be 16
to the one-third or we could write 3 in
our little square root symbol and that
would give us a different solution
squaring any number positive or negative
will give us a positive result
squaring 0 will give us 0 so there is
actually no way for a negative number to
have any real root but we can make
things more inclusive if we invite over
our imaginary friends if we have we
introduce our friend I squared to be
equal to minus 1 then we would have that
I
is equal to the square root of -1
technically - I would also be equal to
the square root of -1 but by convention
we just take positive I to be our square
root minus 1 our principal root then if
we wanted to do the square root of minus
16 we could do that and it would give us
the square root of 16 times the square
root of -1 leading us to an answer of 4i
moral of the story is don't let anyone
tell you that you can't have a square
root you can even take the square root
of an imaginary number but you can see
my other video for how to do that so
that has been our trip underground to
understand square roots if you haven't
already then take a walk near some trees
and try to imagine what their hidden
roots look like I'd like to wish you
happy studying and I hope that you have
an absolutely mathematical day
[Music]
you